let's try some slightly more complicated
equations let's say we have
three times x
plus five
plus five i want to make sure i get all
the colors nice
plus 5 is equal to
is equal to
is equal to 17. so what's different
about this and what we saw in the last
videos all of a sudden now we have this
plus 5. if it was just 3x is equal to 17
you could divide both sides by 3 and you
would get your answer but now this 5
seems to mess things up a little bit now
before we even solve it let's think
about what it's saying let's solve it
kind of
in a tangible way and then we'll solve
it using operations that hopefully will
make sense after that so 3 times x
literally means so let me write it over
here so we have 3 times x so you already
have an x
plus an x
plus an x that right there is a 3x and
then that's plus five and i'm actually
going to write it out as five objects
so plus
one
two
three four five
that this this right here is 3x plus 5
is equal to 17
is equal to 17. so let me write the
equal sign
is equal to 17. now let me draw 17
objects here so 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16
17.
now these two things are equal so
anything you do to this side you'd have
to do that side if we were to get rid of
one object here you'd want to get rid of
one object there in order for the
quality to still be true now what can we
do to both sides of this equation so we
can get it in the form that we're used
to where we only have a 3x on the left
hand side where we don't have this 5.
well ideally we would just get rid of
these five objects here you would
literally get rid of these five objects
one two three four five but like i said
if the original thing was equal to the
original thing on the right if we get
rid of five objects from the left hand
side we have to get rid of five objects
from the right hand side so we have to
do it here too one two three four five
now what is a symbolic way of
representing taking away five things
well you're subtracting five from both
sides of this equation
so that's what we're doing here when we
took away five from the left and from
the right so we're subtracting five from
the left that's what we did here and
we're also subtracting 5 from the right
do that right over there now what does
the left hand side of the equation now
become
the left hand side you have 5 minus 5
these cancel out you're just left with
the 3x
you are just left with it's a different
shade of green you are just left with
the 3
the 3x the 5 and the negative 5
cancelled out and you see that here when
you got rid of these five objects we
were just left with the 3 x's this right
here is the 3x and the whole reason why
we subtracted 5 is because we wanted
this 5 to go away now what does the
right hand side of the equation look
like
so 3x is going to be let me write the
equality sign right under it is equal to
well you can either just do it
mathematically say okay 17 minus 5 17
minus 5 is 12.
or you could just count over here i had
17 things i took away 5 i have 12 left 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 12. that's what
subtraction is it's just taking away
five things so now we have it in a
pretty straightforward form 3x is equal
to 12. all we have to do is divide both
sides of this equation by 3 so we have
so we're just left with an x on the left
hand side so we divide by let me pick a
nicer color than that let me do
let me do this pink color so you divide
the left hand side by three the right
hand side by three and remember what
that's equivalent to the left hand side
none of this stuff exists anymore so we
should ignore it none of this stuff
exists anymore in fact let me let me
clear it out just so that we don't even
have to look at it we subtracted it so
let me clear it
let me clear it over here
let me clear it over here and so now we
are dividing both sides by three divide
the left hand side by three it's one
two three so three groups each of them
have an x in it if you divide this right
hand side by three let's see you have
one
two and three so it's three groups of
four so when you do it mathematically
here the threes cancel out 3 times
something divided by 3 is just the
something so you're left with x
is equal to and then 12 divided by 3 is
4.
12 divided by 3 is 4. you get x is equal
to 4. you get that exact same thing over
here when you divided 3x into groups of
three each of the groups
had an x in it and we divided 12 into
groups of three each of the groups have
a four in it so x must be equal to four
x is equal to 4. let's do another one
and this time i won't draw it all out
like this but hopefully you'll see that
the same type of processes are involved
let's say i have let me scroll down a
little bit let's say i have
7x
so 7
x
7x i'll do a slightly more complicated
one this time 7x minus 2
is equal to
let's say
is equal to i'll make the numbers not
work out nice and clean is equal to
negative
10. now this all of a sudden becomes a
lot more uh maybe you know you have a
negative sign we have a negative over
here but we're going to do the exact
same thing the first thing we want to do
if we want to get the left-hand side
simplified to just 7x is we want to get
rid of this negative 2 and what can we
add or subtract to both sides of the
equation to get rid of this negative 2
well if we add 2 to the left hand side
these two guys will cancel out but
remember this is equal to that if we
want the equality still hold if we add 2
to the left-hand side we also have to do
it to the right-hand side so what is the
new left-hand side going to be equal to
so we have 7x
7x negative 2 plus 2 is just 0. i could
write plus 0 or i could just write
nothing there and i'll just write
nothing so we get 7x is equal to now
what's negative 10
plus 2 and this is a little bit of
review of adding and subtracting
negative numbers remember i'll draw the
number line here for you if i draw the
number line
so if this is 0 this is 1 we could keep
going in the positive direction
negative 10 is out here negative 10
negative 9 negative eight negative seven
there's a bunch of numbers here you know
dot dot dot i don't have space to draw
them all but we're starting at negative
ten
and we're adding two to it so we're
moving in the positive direction of the
number line so we're going 1
so it's negative 8. don't get confused
don't say okay 10 plus 2 is 12 so
negative 10 plus 2 is negative 12. no
negative 10 minus 2 would be negative 12
because you're going more negative here
we have a negative number but we're
going to the right we're going in the
positive direction so this is
negative 8. so we have 7x is equal to
negative 8. so now you might be saying
well how do i how do i
do this type of a problem
you know i have a negative number here
you do it the exact same way we want if
we want to just have an x on the left
hand side we have to divide the left
hand side by 7 so that the 7x divided by
7 just 7s cancel out you're left with x
so let's do that if you divide by 7
those cancel out but you can't just do
it to the left hand side anything you do
the left you have to do the right in
order for the equality to still hold
true so let's divide the right by 7 as
well and we are left with just an x
just an x is equal to negative 8 divided
by 7. we could work it out it'll be some
type of a decimal if you were to use a
calculator or you could just leave it in
fraction form negative 8 divided by 7 is
negative 8 eight-sevenths
negative eight-sevenths or if you wanna
write it as a mixed number x is equal to
seven goes into eight one time and has a
remainder of one so it's negative one
and one-seventh either one would be
acceptable